welcome to another entry in the gameplay
video series for Dragon Age Inquisition
crafting and customization and
Inquisition are the deepest of the
series today we'll look at how you can
make the vast world of Dragon Age URL
create your Inquisitor using one of the
game's many default appearances
Inquisition allows you to play a man or
woman for one of four different races
from humans to the towering qunari class
selection defines your combat style and
role in the party your initial choice
determines both class and starting gear
but your character may involve over time
you can switch weapons and abilities for
both your Inquisitor and your pardon
inquisitions in-depth alchemist system
challenges you to plan ahead with
individual loadouts for each party
member prepare for battle by collecting
herbs and recipes then use them to craft
items like fire resistant tonics or
grenades that I'm douche havoc on your
enemy
as you explore the immense world you
uncover treasures lost to the ages and
Luke even more riches from your fallen
foes hundreds of weapons armor and
accessories can be purchased from
merchants discovered or reclaimed over
the course of your inquisitors tale the
Inquisition smiths and workers stand
ready to stock your armory as well
collect schematics from throughout
Thetis and make them your own outfit
your companions and custom equipment
owned a compliment the distinctive
fighting styles applied credibly rare
master worth materials to craft weapons
that rival those of legend build what's
necessary to tackle the most challenging
opponents in the world and lead the
Inquisition to victory
you